*Crying*
I'm Alice.
Hey Alice.
Alice.
Mom..
Alice please stop avoiding me.
Alice, look at me for a second.
Alice is ...  a newly seperated,
..loser.
Girl: She's so intense.
Alice: No, I'm not.
You and I have got this thing about
you and it's super impressive.
You seem to be handling everything really well.
Alice doesn't know what she wants.
Brutal.
You gotta check yourself, everything is gonna be okay.
When were you gonna tell me that three
strangers were living in your house?
I just always act out on my birthday.
It's like my own personal new year's eve
so I just go like "blooawh"..
And I just reel it back to..  normal.
Did you wash these?
I did, but ehm only because I was doing a load, I've been up since 5:30.
You know I'm 40 right?
Uh, yeah I knew that, like ballpark.
I am not in love with her, okay?
I just love a lot of things about her, like her face and her personality.
Maybe it's fate that they met you.
Hi.